[Music]
in midnight munchies news o submitted by
yogurt and a tube go-gurt I like not a
man took a late night trip to the Waffle
House and cooked his own food after
finding employees asleep oh what a good
Samaritan do they have those in
California no I know I wish to I know
was it in the south for natural
disasters if the Waffle House is still
open
you could still good 24/7 all the time
so they just look at the waffle and the
Waffle House closes that means you gotta
get the [ __ ] out oh it's like the flight
attendants on the plane yeah yeah so
this took place in South Carolina so it
does that count South South Carolina
count us out you asked that same
question I don't know you there yeah I
don't know anything past California well
I mean South Dakota's not the south
yeah I think I think what it is is the
rule of thumb south of Virginia yeah
south of Virginia okay I don't even know
where that is it's south of Washington
it's right here
listen only California there's
California Texas New York everybody else
what Florida yeah that one too yeah we
know that one and the other ones are
kind of like where are you
Vegas somewhere here you know is south
of Virginia all the way down but it
doesn't include Florida Florida's his
own thing
and then you go all the way west to text
stop the Georgia most people will stop
ya start back I mean technically it is
the South but their culture is just
Floridian it's like Hawaii they're
technically West Coast but they're
Hawaii myself
yeah for a Bama oh my god they have that
on NTV now what's that it's like the
Judith
it's like the Jersey Shore but for a
Bama yeah it's gonna kill Alabama Jersey
store yeah I gotta see this [ __ ] I love
watching [ __ ] like that
hell yeah
therefore you did that [ __ ] is my cat
the guilty pleasure oh [ __ ] don't be
like yeah you guys are our garbage yeah
we're definitely garbage people - other
people not for sure everyone's garbage
to someone else
yep one man's trash is another man's
treasure yes this man Alex Bowen here he
posted on Facebook couldn't sleep so I
went to Waffle House guess what everyone
on shift was asleep and then he posted
all these photos of him at 3:00 a.m. at
Waffle House and he ended up making his
own meal why is this tongue out how did
he know where things were II just opened
up the fridge it was like there's a
french toast there's no sleeping yeah
this is a sleeping exam hope they didn't
get fired I know you got suspended
yeah they got suspended for a week oh
that's cool cuz you got a little work
assault
did he pay for the food so he went back
the next day and paid $5.00 for the food
I see
yeah and then also like cuz he had to
cook it yes sirs yeah the waffle house
they were like well we're not happy
about the fact that obviously like if
you know a customer whoo yeah
across the counter and made their own
meal but they ended up saying this quote
obviously alex has some cooking skills
and we'd like to talk to him talk to him
about a job since we may have something
for him but he said since he knows how
to stay awake at that time - yeah that's
awesome he says that they haven't
formally offered him a job yet but they
have reached out to him and so
apparently they're asking him to be a
secret shopper oh that's a dope company
have you guys ever had like a graveyard
shift yeah shit's [ __ ] hard to stay
awake you know they did Studies on
people and I'd do graveyard shifts they
end up having a shorter lifespan oh oh
well I got sick like a [ __ ] I
did graveyard for restaurant work for
about five to six years
no munch that's pretty long but I got
sick yes
dude I got like so damn jealous sick all
the time because I never saw the Sun oh
yeah and then the best hours where the
weekends were like we would close up at
around like 6:00 a.m. so we don't get
home till like 7:00 but had that that
dinner rush that drunk rush and then
when people sober up after the club rush
that was Bank dude some of us like
waiters would make eight hundred to a
thousand and a night Wow yeah as a
waiter yeah those times yeah okay I
didn't get that she got you [ __ ] yeah
dude you just walked in Waffle House
[ __ ] love breakfast food man that's
my [ __ ] dude but I never eat breakfast
food when is breakfast though yeah if I
if it's after to breakfast food it
tastes weird of me eating breakfast food
when the Sun is barely coming up and I
feel in the birds are chirpin and
there's not that much pollution and it
feels like good morning they wouldn't
eat french toast and like ovary the eggs
and hash browns it feels really good but
if it's afterwards I felt like I'm a
sinner and I feel like I'm like that
that club girl that's on a church to
repent for my sins I'm just praying for
you I'd love breakfast food any time any
day specifically I [ __ ] love eggs
eggs like eggs
anything dude I [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
dude [ __ ] house-made sausages bacon
country fried steak with country gravy
oh your stomach doesn't turn on extra
acid during the day I don't know one or
another mother
because I think like so your breakfast
is like cleaner so in the morning I
think I have this amount of stomach acid
uh-huh so it's made perfect for
breakfast food it's kind of light it
just demolishes it then it's if it's
lunchtime or dinner my stomach acid is
up here so I need like Big Mac or steaks
or else if I eat breakfast food is just
it's just gonna burn right through it
breakfast food is [ __ ] up if you're
getting American or Mexican style not
compared to like a wet burrito with
pizza I think it's about the same level
it's just fat in car know what's
interesting it just shows how in tune
you are with your body sound go ooh how
do you forgot your acid in your body
like he just knows his body I could just
feel it like I'm just like you know you
ever have that feeling when you want to
eat something you want you don't want to
eat or you want eat hope sometimes you
want fur or a solid to night cuz he's
like you know I want something you know
kind of help I'm like oh okay okay so
throughout the day it gets more like
dinner that's dinner food yeah you can't
wake up and get steak and fried chicken
for brain you know that's [ __ ] like
oh man who what makes me feel happy
that guy's brave as hell cuz I don't
think I would have the balls to though
huh
I know how to not burn [ __ ] yeah you can
cook and I know how to like make things
to my pellet where I'm like damn is it
mom for me so I guess I get cereal
I don't like Co that much you know I see
really that much like all the students I
have are like the blend what it was way
don't ask me these questions your
Cheerios or something kiks kiks get the
[ __ ] out of this place I like Barry
Barry kicks Barry clips I have like in
the morning every I don't you eat
[ __ ] flaxseed and [ __ ] [ __ ] like
straw and they throw to the milk is you
you are my bro yeah fiber one not to be
hot you [ __ ] 501 [ __ ] with almond
that's good I like really bland flavor
but you can't go as bland as me cuz I do
oatmeal
nothing at all yes I do
you do that to honor a mill all right
all right water not even mill Oh water
just water it's really good if you know
how to cook it right cuz a lot of people
don't know how to make oatmeal I don't
even care if it's cooked right though
that's I like what you won with the
blandness Wow you get a plant trophy in
the morning and then come lunch time you
have a whole bag of gummy bears ready to
devour yeah oh you know though wouldn't
you head it with the brown sugar and the
fruit no that's just so good raisins you
know what I I want to do something like
this sometimes when I go to a restaurant
and I [ __ ] taste the food and I'm
like this cook [ __ ] losses money
gambling or [ __ ] is alcoholic or some
just got beat by his wife or something
because the food tastes like [ __ ] now
you could tell the cook hates his life
by the way that you eat that you're like
what the [ __ ] is this I want to go back
there and I want to cook [ __ ] give me
the ingredients I want to make it so I
could bring it out and [ __ ] eat it
you never felt that before when you go
to a restaurant yeah Denny's [ __ ]
happy with them it's more like just
[ __ ] at least present it like it
might taste good cuz you know the
presentation already is like this don't
taste like [ __ ] cuz that looks like [ __ ]
yeah it looks like they threw the eggs
on the [ __ ] plate like always like
one piece of iceberg lettuce as like
presentation I take the [ __ ] iceberg
lettuce that's true why you putting a
bacon or your meal too because for some
reason they always take an attorney I
know I swear like with every bite I
could [ __ ] taste the sorrow and pain
and hate I'm like oh my god your wife
left you oh and she took the kids and Oh
God
hey but that's like Denny's just like
that there's that one Denny's in k-town
I used to always go to though cuz it was
like the only diner place that's in
k-town really it's six yeah yeah that's
the place I used to always go to India
the most fascinating human being Center
people were butt-naked after the club
okay
yeah that was nice for me if you guys
have this experience where you walk into
like let's say your favorite fast-food
place I'm winking the [ __ ] up no
but like you can create anything you
want because you have the whole kitchen
to your fingertips where'd you leave it
[Laughter]
my favorite places I don't like to touch
the food because they already do it so
well like my bucket up you know I ain't
trying to [ __ ] with the recipe yeah but
do you know how sometimes things just
taste better because it's made for you
exactly I think that that applies to
sandwiches and salads yep they only
taste if I make my own style is I'm very
just not excited yeah it's like it's
like what's that called head jobs you
could do yours better but you still want
it from somebody exactly
yeah yeah yeah yeah no I would prefer my
own hand job over my calmness so kiss
hands put some lotion on look at the
leather face he has on too he refuses to
put anything on his skin I hate lotion
you see so what it is gold is just like
[Music]